[Musique]
décrochage scolaire grossesses précoces
démêlés avec la justice
les raisons qui amènent les jeunes à
l'école de la deuxième chance sont
divers et variés tous sont en revanche
un point commun celui de subir d'énormes
freins sociaux problèmes familiaux
précarité économique vit dans un
quartier difficile autant de difficultés
qui complique leur parcours sur place
une équipe de formateurs reprend les
bases en français mathématiques langues
dans un programme personnalisé défini en
fonction des objectifs du stagiaire des
périodes de stages en entreprise sont
aussi obligatoires
l'institution s'efforce de casser des
codes de l'école classique est de
redonner confiance à des jeunes souvent
démunis
[Musique]